it was it was so sweet backstage you
should see it
the the Teamsters are helping Michael
Moore into the trunk of his limo
now our next presenter is someone
[Applause]
are
our next presenter is someone I consider
a close personal fantasy here is Academy
Award winner Julia Roberts
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi it is my honor tonight to present the
Academy Award for Best Cinematography I
find this a personally fantastic award
because I happen to know what I look
like at five o'clock in the morning when
I go to work the nominees are
Dion BB for Chicago
Edward Lachman for far from heaven
Michael ball house for gangs of new york
Pawel Edelman for the pianist
Konrad L Hall for roads perdition
and the Oscar goes to
konrad l ha
this is the third account
nomination for the late Conrad
he won an Oscar in 1999 for American
beauty and in 1969 for Butch Cassidy and
the Sundance Kid accepting on his behalf
tonight is his son Conrad W Howe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a couple of months ago this industry
lost one of its legends many of you lost
a great friend and collaborator and I
lost my father it's been said that God
gives each and every one of us the gift
of life and what we do with that life is
our gift back to him I can't think of a
better gift than my father dad wherever
you are you will be gone but you will
never be forgotten thank you winning
actress who was nominated tonight for
her performance in About Schmidt
[Music]
every time an Oscar is given out an
agent gets his wings
[Applause]
not only that but every time an Oscar is
given out someone's life is changed
usually for the better
most of the time when the happy event
occurs the recipient is either so
excited or so numb they don't even
remember what they said or did it's only
later when they look back on that
special night that they get give me a
break boy yeah it's only later when they
get that full impact of what happened
here in a film by Academy Award winner
Chuck workman are some Oscar recipients
whose lives were impacted by the
addition of Oscar to their resumes it's
much heavier than you think it's going
to be the little statuette I mean it
weighs like 40 pounds or something like
that it's hotter than anyone can imagine
it is it's then everyone is sweating
Halle Berry doesn't sweat but everybody
else sweats they say your name and I
think is a rush of blood in your ears
because I was clapping Tom Cruise then
you suddenly go into very slow motion
you start to realize I should go but
first kiss your wife the moment my name
was called I was in a state of I was
astonished I was bewildered Snow White
was dancing around it was like hugging a
baby
it honestly seemed as though I was
playing a guy in a movie who just won an
award let's see who should you think
your manager Oh God what's your
manager's name really touched me a big
rush of if I had a heart what would be
called emotion English becomes a second
language
you've got Harvey Weinstein I ran right
to the urinal put the thing right over
top I just had to go to the bathroom so
bad it was unbelievable I've been
nominated five times in four years they
were just probably so glad that finally
get rid of me winning me the Oscar
really improved my sex life considerably
she would like to win another one
[Music]
third after American to win an Oscar for
anything my great-grandkids to talk
about it gave me a sense of my own
identity and allowed me I did to act
with more confidence in the future it
just gives you more strength and power
to continue now some little girl can see
me when and dream about winning Best
Picture as a producer I got to see my
father's face and tears were streaming
down his cheeks when I went out and
danced all night or is the real concrete
tangible memories the only one I really
have is looking down and locking eyes
with Jack Palance your star wars here's
another one
the Journal of Medicine has done the
science Oscar winners live four and a
half years longer than the losers happy
75th anniversary Oscar I'm still younger
than you are it's like a gold dipped Ken
doll happy Anniversary to you happy 75th
birthday dude damn right okay these are
my lips
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]